thank you for joining us i'm john  langler we start though in south  carolina where police say a former nfl  player shot  and killed five people then took his own  life  now investigators are trying to figure  out why it all happened 33-year-old  philip  adams allegedly shot a prominent  columbia south carolina doctor named  robert leslie  his wife and two of their grandchildren  aged five  and nine another person working at that  house was also murdered  a sixth was wounded and is in the  hospital adams was found dead in his own  home nearby  he played five seasons in the nfl from  2010 to 2015 including time with the  oakland raiders we'll have more on this  story later on today